erst knapp und jetzt bekommen beim neuen
video ja dann schaut natürlich geht's
gut ja diese woche kann man schon ein
video irgendwie heute voll habe ich das
gefühl auf jeden fall kann diese woche
ja schon ein video heute kommt das
zweite als ich habe diese woche zwei
videos geschafft ich habe auch schon
drei bei einer prüfung geschrieben
zwei kommen noch dann bin ich endlich
wieder durch und dann geht es auch
wieder los fleiß mit videos aber ich
habe mir natürlich noch die zeit jetzt
genommen bis zweite video zu drehen
diese woche weil 14 echt ein bisschen
wenig ist eigentlich ein thema auf dass
ich ziemlich spontan kommen ich habe
jetzt lange überlegt soll ich dazu jetzt
wirklich ein video machen oder nicht
lohnt sich das überhaupt aber ich finde
es irgendwie schon wichtig so ich meinen
auf youtube oder ich hab ja generell
schon öfter mal in meine meinung sagen
welchen themen gesagt es kam es in
letzter zeit nicht mehr so oft und jetzt
hat sich das halt mal wieder angeboten
jahren sich dreht sich auch um ein thema
das irgendwie ich weiß nicht wer uns
beschreiben soll es ist an sich total
aber trotzdem erreichte sendung jedes
jahr aufs neue wieder irgendwelche
komischen schlagzeilen oder irgendwelche
komischen auftritte die dann halt doch
immer relativ viral gehen und so auch
dieses jahr deswegen bin ich das video
gekommen ihr habt ja wahrscheinlich
schon am titel oder im gesamtjahr
gesehen es geht heute um deutschland
sucht den superstar
die wohl bekannteste talentshow aus
deutschland österreich schweiz und das
war es dann aber auch da gibt es ja
schon mega lang ich habe das früher auch
echt sehr sehr gerne geguckt früher hat
mich das erste mal unterhalten vor allem
wenn diese chance am ende wo es darum
ging wer kann am besten singen fand
nicht echt cool
warum weil ich heute etwas kleiner war
und ist irgendwie cool fand nur deshalb
auch schon so keine ahnung 19 jahre her
ich würde sagen jetzt in letzter zeit
also die letzten jahre hat mich das
wirklich überhaupt nicht mehr
interessiert und ich habe immer so ein
riesen bogen drum gemacht gut egal also
das format deutschland sucht den
superstar gibt es ja echt schon mehrere
jahre ich würd mal locker schätzen 15
jahre keine ahnung ich kenne mich da
jetzt nicht aus und ihr müsst euch
vorstellen also das weiß ich halt
einfach weil ich öfter mal mit menschen
geredet habe die da in der materie drin
sind die sich auskennen oder womöglich
sogar für arbeiten so vor zehn jahren
hatte deutschland sucht den superstar
wirklich bombastische quoten das waren
dann so zuschauermengen von
keine ahnung 789 bis zu zehn millionen
zuschauer pro sendung und das ist
natürlich das worauf es für den sender
darauf ankommt ich meine je mehr leute
schauen desto mehr geld fließt und so
weiter und zehn millionen zuschauer dass
es verdammt gut ich würde mal schätzen
in deutschland schauen vielleicht 30
millionen menschen abends fernsehen und
davon dann ein drittel deutschland sucht
den superstar ist ja echt eine super
quote so es ist aber das problem in den
letzten jahren die quote geht halt immer
jedes jahr ist die schlechte geht
durchgehend runter müsst ihr euch
vorstellen früher haben sie es zehn
millionen menschen geguckt und heute im
jahr 2018 wenn es gut läuft schalten da
vielleicht mal drei millionen das weiß
ich auch nicht ganz genau aber würde ich
mal schätzen können auch ein bisschen
mehr sein aber es hat sich auf jeden
fall halbiert das auf jeden fall also
schauen wir noch die hälfte wie vor zehn
jahren kann man ungefähr so sagt warum
das so ist ich bin jetzt auch kein
experte aber ich glaube das konzept
irgendwann wird zwei mal langweilig
weißt du wenn es immer gleich abläuft
und man das ganze schon zehn jahre
gesehen hat rechts nicht aufmachen so
und jetzt muss man ja irgendwie sehen
dass das ganze ich meine es hat ja namen
so das kennt jeder jeder in deutschland
hat den namen deutschland sucht den
superstar schon mal gehört ich glaube
jeder verbindet damit eigentlich das
gleiche ist eine talentshow die aber
eigentlich von keinem mehr wirklich
ernst genommen wird irgendwelche
vermeintlichen vollidioten werden am
anfang schwer los gestellt am ende
gewinnt an einer den im nächsten jahr
keiner mehr kennt ja immer das gleiche
jetzt muss man aber irgendwie schauen
noch relevant zu bleiben wie kann man
die quoten wieder zumindest auf diesem
level halten und das machen sie dieses
jahr ich weiß nicht ob dieses jahr zum
ersten mal
aber es werden zum beispiel auch von
dsds videos auf youtube hochgeladen ich
glaube damals wurde das auf clipfish
hochgeladen aber jetzt laden ist ein
wirklich auf youtube hoch mit erfolg
kann man so sagen ist doch eigentlich
der anlass gewesen wie soll ich wieder
drauf gekommen bin ich war in den
youtube trends unterwegs und da war
wirklich in den trends relativ viel
voller mit dsds und ich habe einfach mal
mir ein video angeschaut weil ich keine
ahnung ich bin ich draufgekommen und
zwar war das ein beitrag der hatte da
schon echt juror schätzen so 78
hunderttausend klicks wirklich eine
menge kommentare wo sich eigentlich
alle leute über die person die in dem
video ads vorkamen total lustig gemacht
haben und jeder kommentare h was ein
vollidiot es war alles voll mit solchen
kommentaren weist ein idiot 2018
blablabla ja die rede ist von diesem
video ich würde das dann auch ziemlich
viele von euch gesehen der ist es 2018
amadeus holte video von edouard aubery
und die forelle von franz schubert das
haben sich jetzt schon 154 millionen
menschen angesehen ich wette auf
facebook auch noch einmal zwei millionen
also den amadeus den kenne nicht viele
so und wenn man dann halt ob dieses
video geht ich bin eigentlich so jemand
liest und erst mal kurz die kommentare
ob sich das lohnt anzuschauen oder nicht
und in den kommentaren wurde dieser
junge mann halt wirklich durchgehend
ausgelacht beleidigt und sonstwas und
dann denkt man sich erstmal soja es
wahrscheinlich eh dem darsteller der
dann wieder bezahlt wurde dass er
irgendeinen blödsinn gemacht und die
leute interessiert ist weil sie sich
darüber lustig machen können und ich
habe mir das viel wie möglich komplett
angeschaut und ich habe schon so am
anfang gemerkt also wenn das
geschauspielert ist dann ist es wirklich
ein guter schauspieler
weil eigentlich kann man das nicht so
schauspielern finde ich und ich hab dann
relativ zu anfang von dem video schon
gemerkt dass mit dem amadeus weiß ich
nicht er kam mir ein bisschen so rüber
wie viele personen die ich schon mal in
seinem buch wir haben da meiner schule
sein buch gelesen da ging es um so einen
jungen der hatte autismus oder das
asperger syndrom und genauso auch wenn
ich das nur gelesen haben aber genau so
kam dieser amadeus für mich rüber und
ich habe mich damit dann ein bisschen
beschäftigt so weil es mich interessiert
hat unter dem video diesen kommentar
gelesen schade dass fast niemand sie
dass sie einen tisch muss leidet aber
ist ja klar dass rtl selbst daran nicht
zurückschreckt hauptsache das
selbstwertgefühl der meisten gesteigert
sich jetzt wieder nachdem ihr das
gesehen habt weil halt wirklich alles
voll war
alle haben sich darüber lustig gemacht
habe ich ja schon gesagt wobei man auch
sagen muss ich glaube der kommentar
jetzt auch schon so 1000 wunder gleich
wenn man sehr viel haben wir darunter
recht gegeben und ich konnte so ein paar
umstimmen
dass das vielleicht nicht so cool ist
oder nicht so witzig und man sich da
jetzt nicht direkt darüber lustig machen
soll klar kann man sagen es ist ja jedem
selbst überlassen ob er da hingeht oder
nicht und jeder der da hingeht muss auch
damit rechnen ich finde immer man kann
ja seinen freunden vorsingen und dann
weiß man ob man sie
kann oder nicht also jeder muss auch
damit rechnen dass man vorgeführt werden
könnte ja so war es hat auch in diesem
fall und der amadeus der tat mir
wirklich von minute zu minute immer mehr
leid weil eigentlich ihr müsst euch
vorstellen es ist ja eine talentshow da
geht es darum zu sehen ob man gut singen
kann oder nicht es geht ja darum den
talent zu finden und wenn man halt nicht
gut singen kann dann ist das eben so
dann kann man dem ganzen auf den cup
setzen person kann ich singen fertig
oder das ding ist ist halt auch nicht
gut für die quote die menschen wollen
was sehen irgendwer benimmt sich total
affig
das ist geil dass neben war dieses video
wird irgendwie so neun minuten und von
minute eins bis vier kommt er halt rein
stellt sich vor sinkt das war es und die
anderen fünf minuten wird er einfach
fünf minuten lang total bloßgestellt
also wirklich ich dachte irgendwann
reicht's auch immer weiß schon immer das
gleiche und dann mit diesen effekten
blablabla fünf minuten wird jemand
bloßgestellt das geht in den fünf
minuten nicht darum ob er singen kann
und am ende die talentshow gewinnt es
geht darum wie komisch sein charakter
ist das hat für mich eigentlich gar
nichts mit der eigentlichen idee von dem
ganzen zu tun gut wäre mir eigentlich
total egal gewesen wenn da irgendwas
hingegangen wäre er wirklich total in
schuss hat und von sich selber überzeugt
ist und dann ein bisschen bloßgestellt
oder auf die schnauze fliegt gut kann
man sehen wie man will aber ist dann
auch mal okay für nicht nur jetzt in
diesem fall mark zurück zu dem autismus
erst mal vielleicht für die die nicht
wissen was das ist es ist einfach so
eine art entwicklungsstörungen jemand
entwickelt sich etwas anders als andere
mensch ich bin jetzt auch keinen
facharzt entweder ich geben welche
speziellen verhaltensmuster sind halt
anders sachen wie gestik mimik ironie
oder so kann man nicht so einfach
verstehen wie andere menschen also was
sind halt einflüsse davon das buch was
wir damals in der schule gelesen haben
da ging es um jemanden der hatte das
asperger-syndrom so hieß es und ich kann
das jetzt natürlich auch nicht
versichern das könnte jetzt auch
kompletter blödsinn seien was ich
erzähle aber ich bin mir schon ziemlich
sicher auch was ich noch so im internet
darüber herausgefunden habe es ist eine
form von autismus autismus ist nicht
heilbar oder so ist damit zu definieren
dass er halt überhaupt keine ironie
versteht nicht so wenig die gestik
versteht und wenn man sich das video
anschaut da merkt man auch so dass
ziemlich viel ironie so von der jury
kommt und
das aber gar nicht so wirklich versteht
und da eigentlich steht und sich so
denkt herr isla bonita und halt einfach
so sein ding durchziehen will hier steht
auch zb beeinträchtigungen ist vor allem
die fähigkeit nicht sprachliche signale
gestik mimik blickkontakt bei anderen
personen zu erkennen diese auszuwerten
oder selbst auszusenden
also das war für mich eigentlich klar
dass das er halt an dieser krankheit
leidet und wie auch immer ja da gelandet
ist ich weiß ich nicht das kann ich auch
nicht verstehen wie die eltern so
jemanden dann ja mit diesem
ausgangspunkt dahin schicken aber das
war wirklich eine sache also dieser
junge tat mir so leid und wieso dann
sowas so ausgenutzt wird und ein 45
minuten lang bloßgestellt wird und dann
daraus geht ich meinen der kann doch
jetzt gerade nicht mehr auf die straße
gehen und das finde ich echt ziemlich
traurig deswegen habe ich dieses video
gemacht um einfach mal zu sagen guckt so
einen scheiß am besten gar nicht weil im
endeffekt schaut man das ja nur um sich
irgendwie selber ein bisschen besser zu
fühlen haha was ein affe obwohl er ja
wirklich eigentlich gar nichts dafür
kann das ist halt eine krankheit und die
hat der sender schön ausgenutzt um ein
bisschen an der quote zur arbeit meiner
meinung nach deswegen dieses video dazu
einfach mal meine meinung dazu was sich
vielleicht auch noch dazu sagen können
ich habe schon mal mit jemandem geredet
er auch daran teilgenommen hat und es
ist halt so dass man davor irgendwie
mehrfach schon gecastet wird ob man dann
wirklich in diese show kann und vor der
wirklichen jury das präsentieren kann
oder ob man halt einfach zu langweilig
dafür ist und dann diese extremfälle
über die man sich lustig machen kann
werden halt dann zum beispiel weiter
gelassen und das ist ja eigentlich gar
nicht der sinn davon klar viele sind
auch irgendwelche bezahlten schauspieler
aber bei ihm zum beispiel bin ich mir
sicher dass es nicht so ist er hatte da
wirklich glaube ich die hoffnung dass er
da weit kommen er hat nämlich auch ein
eigener youtube-kanal wo videos
hochgeladen hat vor drei jahren schon
und ich glaube nicht dass es so weit
zurück inszeniert ist von deutscher
sucht den superstar wo er halt auch
schon so überzeugt sind ähnlich wie es
halt auch in dem video also man geht er
halt durch dieses stufige casting kommt
dann wenn man glück hat irgendwann zu
dieser hauptjury und an sich wird auf
der komplette auftritt noch einmal
ungeschnitten bisher also die person mit
der ich geredet habe die konnte es
diesen auftritt den sie selber ja
gemacht hat im endeffekt im fernsehen
gar nicht wiedererkennen bei der tour
anders war das war total anders diese
gestiken und mimiken den dann ab und zu
da rein geschnitten werden die sind gar
nicht teil dieser eigentlichen dieses
eigentlichen auftritt sondern sie werden
im nachhinein dann noch aufgenommen
damit das ganze dramatischer wird und so
weiter gut soviel dazu wir können gern
mal eure meinung in die kommentare
schreiben wenn ihr das video gesehen
habe oder den beitrag und euch darüber
lustig gemacht habt seht das noch von
der anderen seite ich finde das
eigentlich ziemlich wichtig und ja ich
hoffe dass wir dadurch gefallen dass
nach oben da wir sonst in der nächsten
woche wieder und ich wünsche euch eine
schöne woche